the Santiago Cabrera here from salvation
and I want to ask you right now season
two how's it going it's going great it's
just been we've just delve deeper into
the world and you get to know your
characters more and she's full of
surprises it's been a really good season
you say that your character is part Elan
musk in what ways well he's so you know
one of the great minds of today and
someone that yeah you know people go to
to fix things to kind of he's you know
he cares about the planet he cares about
humanity he cares about people needs you
know also someone whose voice is heard
and has and not everyone's a fan either
on the show the world's falling apart
and we're worried about that asteroid
that's gonna hit the earth possibly yeah
how are you gonna stop all this from
happening well we've got so like the
government has given me so many
facilities to do stuff there's been so
many different projects and ideas but
the clever thing that they do about the
show is that it goes in so many
directions that it becomes about so many
other things as well but I can guarantee
that that that something will be wrapped
up this season and leave something
really exciting for the next one
really okay if the world was about to
end we'll be the last thing you would do
family time for sure there's a basement
home with just got on it like my wife
and kid yeah to spend time a little more
you have a two-year-old right yeah yeah
yeah how is that how is how is that your
fatherhood it's incredible it's just
amazing it's exhausting but it's you
know like it beats everything yeah it is
the greatest thing that's the greatest
thing yeah all right can I ask you about
big little lives as little wiser I hear
it's going well I was there was talks
about me going back they they did reach
out but I think you know was that it was
same date similar dates but I've been
getting some nice messages from people
saying we miss you but we've got Merrill
that's gonna say what did you hear about
Meryl Streep just that you know it's
incredible to have her on board I'm
excited to watch it was just it's great
to still be part of that family so yeah
yeah I'm sure it'll be a really good
second turn your character had that
steamy affair with Reese's girl yeah
yeah that was great fun yeah great fun
she was great she was game and and she's
so great to work with and creative and
it was a you know Jean mark as well it's
such a good group of people what is it
that makes that show so special because
everyone
I think it's just you know it really
gets into the humanity of people it's
not just sort of madhavgarh deeper layer
and it's smartly put together as well
and it's just it really goes for the
truth and for things that we can all
identify with no matter where you know
they're rich people but at the end of
the day they're human beings you know
that's what it ain't that the truth out
your core audience tell everybody what
you call whatever so much yeah for
salvation your salvation ourselves
they're deep in it aren't they yes so
deep in it yeah what is it like what
kind of things do you hear from the
salvie's well they want to know what's
going on next they're all surprised I'm
vice president now and I had a guy at
the airport when I arrived here in San
Diego they just come up through this
huge smart goes you're Darius and we're
just getting I'll of Darius tans Manny's
crap he can be a jerk the way he goes
about things sometimes but you know so
you're like okay alright so what you
guys do it's unique that it seems like
you know somebody CBS series have both
that connection with their fans and
especially summer series they form a
quick good actually yeah it's such a
quicker and people are so in it and they
just have all these theories about but
they do it's just like a lot of you know
oh my god moment so the thriller element
is really kicks off this season you know
so it really goes it's kind of like you
know you want to know what happens next
this is streaming live do you want to
break any news until anybody anything
that's coming up here it is I'm hooking
you up right now
uh what can I not really I can just say
that you know I've just read episode 13
where she we're gonna about this not to
shoot it now and the finale I mean if
you think this season is full of
surprises just wait till till the end
because you'll be uh I was shocked and
they'll be shot be good
appreciate
[Music]